congratulations on this Bradley Cooper
Lady Gaga song cuz I think it's
fantastic that Bradley Cooper has the
number one song it's crazy
I mean he's not known for sing out and
and also because you know Bradley he's
always and he's on the show like he's
such a modest guy like he's not I don't
get the fact like some of us like
they're googling our chart positions
like that's not him right so like every
now and then when I see it's like number
one it's like and it's not like we're
super close but I'll send him a text me
like do you understand like you have
like the number one cylinder like I've
had the number one single like once
before in my life once with Bru Nora's
right right yeah so like I'm like you
and Bruno or my muses like you are
obviously the only way I can get to
number one Bradley Cooper is crazy cuz I
dunno Bradley Cooper and I remember when
he first started shooting a star is born
I was invited to his home yeah he says I
want to show you something he showed me
some clips of him singing in the early
stages of filming the movie and he says
I want to know what you think cuz you
know I was a judge on America's Got
Talent yeah
people want to know my thoughts so I
said to him you know and I wasn't
blowing smoke up his ass yeah I'm pretty
legit yeah I said to him I kind of tell
you that's you sing and he goes yeah I
go I think people will believe that you
can st. yeah I mean it sounds really
good it's it sounds really good that we
did some stuff like early on in the
studio I mean you know Gaga produced
really most of it it's like the her
vision but we're in the studio he was
wanted to see what his voice was like
explore we recorded like a did yet but
when he recorded the Green Day song
could he pull it off yeah it was great
and then he did like this radio I had in
this lovely fall said I mean I have
these two if I ever get hard up for
money else you know chances I've got the
Bradley Cooper demos right but um no and
he does and the other thing is he loves
music so much that I think it was like
such a labor of love to like get it
right like when I sometimes see movies I
could be like oh that's not really how
they do it right you know like and he
just like made sure that it was just
like bulletproof like the him playing
it's so legit tell me how that works
so who contacts you does Lady Gaga
contact you and say look I'm doing a
star is born she created all the music
we're working with someone like her like
80% of its in
like she you're just there to like you
know maybe offer a cordially right but a
genius
she's a genius and the voice the songs
of visions so we I had worked with her
on our album Joanne write and lead got
close work working on that I knew her
ten years ago when she just started like
when she'd just come out with just dance
but hadn't seen it for ten years we
worked together on Joanne and then
you're a good-looking guy I imagined
these women they all come on to you too
right I mean you have to bat him off
with a stick no I was married and where
you work yeah yeah sorry sorry I mean
you know I'm just imagining but you know
when you're when you're working with a
woman yeah and you're that intimate and
you're listening to her voice and you
know someone is powerful what do you got
I figured maybe it turns romantic or
something I turn into like uncle or dad
real quick oh that's kind of yeah I
think so sorry I'm sorry you so
professional huh